hi my name is marquez and i'm a student
at stevens tech and i'm studying
business and technology information
systems and marketing and as many of you
guys already know me i'm a youtube video
producer so if you want to check out
some of that work then bam it'll be
right there you can check out some of
the rest of my videos so basically what
i like about studying business is that
you actually learn a lot about the world
around you outside of college and what i
mean by that is basically everything
that you work hard to do or everything
that you work towards or that you
surround yourself with if you think
about it it's all financially inspired
if you know what i mean 99 of the
products you see on the store shelves
around you of the websites that you
visit and the hard work that goes on
around you ultimately has some sort of
financial background and chances are
it's really interesting to study
majoring in a business field should you
choose to do so can be one of the most
eye-opening things you learn a lot about
people and social and and how they spend
their money the psychology of it and why
they spend it and where and how often
it's really cool stuff and one of the
coolest things i've learned about so far
is what's called consumer behavior it's
how marketing affects the choices that
people make and it affects millions of
people all around the world like
literally every day so honestly if you
want to get into something that is is
inspired by a lot of people that a lot
of people get into this is definitely a
field to take note of so if you're not
in college yet or if you're just
watching this video i have a tiny bit of
advice for you what's your dream job
what is your dream job shoot for that
through what interests you honestly if
you're passionate about something then
you have a much better chance of success
in a field against someone who's not
really as passionate about it so when
you're passionate you put in the extra
work and that's what gets you the
advantage to really make an impact in
that field even leave your own little
dent in the universe
that's what i got for you guys
just so you know this is a video for a
contest so i would really appreciate if
you click the first link in the
description and hit that green vote
button to vote for this entry
now excuse me while i go study for
finals thanks for watching guys peace